señor presidente en esta votación hay
nueve por el Sí y cero por el no se
acuerda la resolución unánime Donald
Trump tendrá que comparecer ante la
cámara de representantes la comisión que
Investiga el asalto al Capitolio del 6
de enero de 2021 acusó el ex presidente
de tener un plan premeditado para
declararse ganador de las elecciones
aunque perdiese
él es la única persona en el centro de
la historia de lo que sucedió el 6 de
enero
debe responder ante millones de
estadounidenses cuyos votos quería
desechar como parte de su esquema para
permanecer en el poder
parece poco probable que el comité pueda
interrogar al expresidente Trump puede
recurrir la citación y en última
instancia negarse a contestar a las
preguntas si habló en su propia
plataforma 3 social
Por qué no me pidió la comisión no
seleccionada que testificara hace meses
porque esperaron hasta el final los
últimos momentos de su reunión porque la
comisión es una basura Total que solo ha
servido para dividir aún más a nuestro
país que por cierto va muy mal unasme
reír en todo el mundo la comisión
argumentó que Trump sabía que había
perdido querían usar el hecho de que los
demócratas votan más por correo para
frenar el conteo en ese contexto se
conoció una declaración inédita de
Victoria electoral también llamados a la
violencia de asesores de Trump y nuevos
vídeos de los sucesos del 6 de enero
cuando partidarios de Trump
interrumpieron en la sede del congreso
para evitar que se certificase El
Triunfo de Joe biden